hey everybody good to see you i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message we are live streaming on rumble
ut youtube
and blaze tv
uh don't forget to share subscribe tap
notification bells it's march 8th
2022.
there's a lot going on in the world uh i
said to my guys this morning like let's
just not do russia ukraine today the
whole thing you know they talk about the
fog of war the whole thing feels so
messy to me and so
uh confusing and i don't mean confusing
like like we can't ascertain truth out
of it i mean that our media is such
in such a state of disarray there are so
many liars everywhere people who have
lied about everything for so long that
trying to pilfer some truth out of it is
really really tough um you know as i
said yesterday it's like if you think
the new york times and washington post
lie about everything then why would they
not be lying about this i don't know
exactly
how to frame this in a way that is going
to make some sense to you and i think
also you know everybody pretends to be
an expert about absolutely everything
and i don't think i have to do that here
i will do the best i can to communicate
this stuff to you as honestly as
possible and we'll do more as as it
comes but i was just like you know i
just don't feel like doing it today if
you want a little more though on the
general
ideas about geopolitics and
international relations and things like
that i interviewed nikki haley who's the
former u.s ambassador to the un we put
it up yesterday you know she was uh un
ambassador under trump and i know
there's a little tension there between
the base and herfer after the january 6
things and all that but she really lays
out an interesting case for you know
sort of peace through strength and you
know carry a big stick and speak softly
and all that good stuff and then i
talked to her about my more libertarian
approach to things so we have a really
interesting conversation uh part one is
up on youtube the full thing is up at
reubenreport.locals.com
uh and uh as you know i am in the midst
of recording the audiobook for dumper in
this country that's what i did for five
hours after the show yesterday and i'll
be doing for five hours after the show
today the book is on sale right now you
can get it at daverubin.com book that's
the pre-sell of course the book comes
out on april 12th i think you're going
to dig it i'm really enjoying doing the
audiobook because i can land all the
funny stuff and do it just exactly as i
like with the pauses in the right spots
and all that good stuff so i do think
you will dig it and as i said if you uh
if you buy it during the pre-sale time
that counts towards week one which gets
us on the new york times and i only want
to get on the stupid list so that i can
tell those people to go f themselves
okay all of that being said today we're
going to be talking about uh this don't
say gay bill here in florida and uh long
story short you can say gay and there's
actually nothing about gay in the
freaking bill itself but everybody's
melting down and then we're going to
compare and contrast what's going on
here in florida which is at obviously
the forefront the forefront of freedom
here in the united states versus what's
going on in places like california new
york and some other places when it comes
to the cobit stuff and believe it or not
in new york they still want young
toddlers in masks just crazy stuff but
before we get to any of that i want to
talk to you guys about zstack
and have a sip of coffee uh you know if
the last two years have taught us
anything it's that you must take control
of your own health it's clear that you
can't simply rely on the government or
big pharma to protect you or your family
that's where z stack comes in z-stack is
a specially formulated immune boosting
supplement that includes zinc
quiceridine vitamin c and vitamin d
formulated by dr vlad zelenko the
world-renowned dr president trump
credited with his early
treatment protocol when he got kovid and
his decision to take hcq
zstack has been
scientifically formulated is kosher and
gmp certified and is produced right here
in the usa although mass mandates are
being lifted and vaccine mandates are no
longer enforced in several states uh
we'll get to that in a little bit
viruses are still out there by taking
z-stack daily you're super charging your
immune system z-stack is formulated to
help combat any and all variants as well
as the common cold and flu so i
encourage you to start taking it now to
stay ahead of any potential future
variants by preparing your immune system
and going about living your life go to
zstacklife.com
dave today and enter the promo code dave
to get a small discount off your first
order that's zstacklife.com
dave promo code dave and now back to me
okay so the big thing in the culture war
which is always raging on we are stuck
in this endless ridiculous culture war
that never stops and is fueled by
algorithms and liars and media buffoons
versus the rest of us uh the big thing
is this don't say gay bill that they're
telling us about in florida now the bill
itself doesn't even have the word gay in
it
uh but it has caused a complete meltdown
amongst our media elite our blue check
twitterati and everyone else so i'm
going to tell you exactly what's in the
bill but before we do that here's what's
going on in
florida schools this is florida senate
democrats going to a school and in case
you don't know they love the gays
[Music]
these people are insane absolutely
insane uh that's out of school i think
we should just play it again um
what are they doing these are supposed
to be teachers
look at these
gay gay gay i'm gay she's gay
everybody's gay yippity-dippity
i'm honestly not sure that i'm gay after
this uh i'm married to a dude it's true
my husband's gay um and that's uh you
know is what it is uh but i can't take
these people anymore and i'm thinking
about returning the uh the gay card
these people are absolutely ridiculous
and actually joking aside
if you're pro-gay and what i mean by
pro-gay is if you me if you believe that
that people uh have sexual preference um
and should be able to enter whatever
relationship they want with another
consenting adult if you if you
fundamentally believe that if you
believe in individual rights and all of
these things you have to be radically
against these people because these
people are making all gay people look
completely ridiculous and i actually
think there's an awful lot of gay people
that are completely against these people
now why is it that these adults are
parading around the school
chanting gay gay gay everybody's gay
you're gay you're gay extra credit if
you're gay why why is it that they're
doing it well it's because of this bill
that is in the florida state senate
right now that they're calling the don't
say gay bill and that sounds very scary
right oh my god you can't say gay but
we're for free speech why can't you say
gay
here is a
reporter evan donovan on local florida
channel explaining what is actually in
bill
1557 and again the word gay
is not in it officially entitled
parental rights in education it forces
school districts to adopt procedures
that quote reinforce the fundamental
right of parents to make decisions
regarding the upbringing and control of
their children that includes making
school districts notify parents if there
are changes to the student's mental
emotional or physical health or
well-being not encouraging students to
withhold information from parents
allowing parents to access their child's
student records letting parents refuse
any health care services offered by the
school and getting parental permission
before administering any health
screening or well-being questionnaire
the bill also forces schools to respond
to parent concerns within a week and
resolve those issues within a month if
the school can't or won't parents can
escalate those concerns to the state for
a resolution or they can sue
okay so reporter evan donovan he had a
little run in with desantis about this a
day or two ago we'll get to that in just
a second but what he laid out there
is basically what's in the bill to
expand on it a little bit more in
essence if you are in kindergarten to
third grade that's what this is about
kindergarten to third grade they can't
teach you in a state school about
sexuality or gender identity
now that has nothing to do with being
anti-gay or anti-trans or anything else
why i really think about this for a
second especially for those of you that
are parents really think about the same
you had a second grader
a second grader seven years old eight
years old okay i was just at my niece's
uh birthday party on sunday she turned
seven years old these kids we we were
playing we were making the uh the putty
what do they call it not the putty what
do they make the slime you make the
slime it's like with shaving cream they
love slime and painting and all this
stuff it's a bunch of kids they want
nothing to do and they know nothing
about sexuality or sexual preference or
anything else why in the world would you
want to send your kid to a state-run
school where most likely an activist is
going to start bringing up sexual
attraction to them and sexual preference
and sexual identity whether they think
they're a boy or a girl or anything else
especially when you know that these
teachers are mostly activists and they
will always endorse the most extreme
ideas that's just true that's just true
that's not a that has nothing to do with
being gay or anything else why would you
want your young
kindergartner first grader second grade
or third grader being taught about sex
in school that's what this is really
about but now can we pull up the still
there of the of the bullets of what else
is in there so this is hb 1557 this is
what all of the democrats and the media
are going crazy about these people lie
about
absolutely everything let's just go
quickly through these five bullets uh
what's in the bill they you should have
notify parents of changes to health or
well-being well okay that does seem like
if a kid at school uh was having health
problems or seemed depressed or
something like that it does seem like
that shouldn't just be dealt with within
the school it seems like a teacher or an
administrator or principal might want to
communicate that to the parent because
ultimately the parent is the one
responsible for the child's well-being
okay bullet number two
don't encourage withholding info from
parents
well of course that makes sense what
right if the school knew that a child
was deeply depressed about something was
really upset about something was in some
sort of pain having some sort of
existential crisis and again we're
talking about kids that are in first or
second grade this isn't about 10th
graders right that are a little more
evolved 12th graders that are that are
really figuring stuff out of course you
wouldn't want to withhold that
information if you had a kid
in school that was in a lot of pain
whatever that is physical pain mental
pain emotional pain why would you be
withholding that would that make sense
does the state own the children not yet
uh bullet number three allow parents to
access child student records
well okay that that makes sense if a
kid's acting out in class and they get a
bad mark he's talking a lot he makes a
lot of jokes whatever it might be of
course the parent should be able to see
what's in this kid's records again why
why is the good position here that we
should hide things from parents unless
you guys are up to something really
nefarious and i think you are bullet
number four
let parents refuse school health care
services okay i could see this one being
slightly
more controversial obviously i'm okay
with that of course parents ultimately
should decide what their children are
injected with or what pills they take
etc etc we all know this i think that's
a i think that should be the default
position of most people um but i suppose
in the crazy world that we live in it
would be somewhat controversial if some
kids didn't want to be injected and
other kids did in which case i think if
you really care about your kid you'll
just take them out of school but i'll at
least grant like there's some debate
there somewhere on that one okay and the
fifth bullet point get parental
permission for health screening yeah
okay that's fine why wouldn't you just
want a parent if you go to the zoo
remember when you went to the zoo in
school remember when you took the trip
to washington dc and you went and you
saw the white house and all that stuff
you'd have to have a parental document
it was a small piece of paper it was
usually about you know yay
yay long and a parent would have to sign
it just to say okay i know my kid's
going somewhere so i think related to
health or related to what's going on in
the school or whether the kid is
depressed or in pain or whatever else it
is these are all obviously
sane things but the democrats they
cannot
do anything sanely and then they get the
media to fuel it and then the entire
machine the entire algorithmic machine
the way twitter shows you the topics ron
desantis hates gay people doesn't want
anyone to say gay it's complete
and abject nonsense uh here's governor
ron desantis on tucker carlson
uh explaining what's actually going on
here
well tucker none of the adults were
wearing masks and it seemed to me that
someone told those kids they had to do
it so i just wanted to make it very
clear they do not need to be doing it
obviously in florida it's a free state
you can do it but i think it's also
important to point out that there's no
reason to do it for for young and
healthy kids especially in the state of
florida we never had a mass mandate of
course but our guidance from our health
department is not to wear these cloth
masks and i think it needs to be said
because people have been lied to for two
years and so i was uh i didn't want it
to be thinking that like they were told
to do this by me because i certainly
wouldn't do that and you know they talk
about oh by letting someone have a
choice to take off their mask and
welcoming
all right guys my bad we i threw the
wrong clip there so here is ron desantis
now getting into a bit of a scuffle with
the same reporter who i just showed you
from that local
news affiliate here in florida about the
don't say gay bill
what critics call the don't say gay bill
is on the senate does it say that in the
bill
does it say that in the bill
i'm asking you to tell me what's in the
bill because you are pushing false
narratives it doesn't matter what
critics say it says it bans classroom
instruction on sexual identity and
gender orientation for who
for for grades pre-k through three so
five-year-old six-year-old
seven-year-olds and um the idea that you
wouldn't be honest about that and tell
people what it actually says it's why
people don't trust people like you
because you peddle false narratives and
so we disabuse you of those narratives
and we're going to make sure that
parents are able to send their kid to
kindergarten without having some of this
stuff injected into their school
curriculum okay
sorry about our little screw up there
that one's on me uh but you can see
what's going on here which is that
desantis really has become a master in
how to deal with the media the fact that
reporters are going up to him and
talking about the don't say gay bill
already shows you that the reporters
have they've swallowed the narrative
right like they've taken that blue pill
and by just calling it the don't say
gabriel they're already giving oxygen to
something that deserves no oxygen but
desantis just pushes back and that's
exactly what you must do you cannot play
their games and and they get everybody
to play their games and once you start
playing their games it's an endless
quicksand now here is the video
that we showed you a couple of days
because desantis has just been knocking
it out of the park here's desantis a
couple of days ago telling those
university of south florida students to
take off their masks
you do not have to wear those masks i
mean please take care of them honestly
it's not doing anything and we got to
stop with this theater so if you want to
wear it fine but this is this is
ridiculous
all right well it's good to be at usf
okay so what happened after that well
after that then everyone said desantis
there's a is a bully he forced the kids
to take off their mess he told him it
was their choice he didn't force anyone
to do anything you can even take you see
the kid taking it off and like the smile
on his face like oh i can breathe again
so desantis is really fighting the
machine right now i want to contrast
that
to
new york governor kathy hoechel or as i
call her kathy c word
because as they start taking masks off
in new york at least in parts of new
york
she's very concerned that the masked
might now get bullied even though if
they were the ones bullying everyone for
the last two years will not have any
tolerance for people who are questioning
someone's own personal decision to do
what they want if people want to
continue wearing masks they allowed to
continue wearing masks and i don't want
any issues related to that and i want to
be very clear on that we will not stand
for any bullying or ostracization or
harassment of an individual or a
business or anyone who chooses to wear a
mask
all right so this is totally
extraordinary and i'm not just talking
about her eyebrows and she's definitely
on the pelosi root whatever's going
there like what did these people do
like they're just trying to look evil
it's weird but what is she really saying
there it's actually pretty amazing she's
saying we will not tolerate any bullying
now first off these are the bullies
you kathy c word you are the bully you
are the mandate bully you are the vaxxo
you are the people that have been
bullying everyone for the last two years
to do exactly what you want but also
what do you mean as the governor we will
not tolerate any bullying of kids or
people or businesses that want to wear
masks now i'm not for bullying
inherently everyone can make whatever
choice they want that's what i have
that's what i believe in it's what i've
pushed this entire time right but what
do you mean we will not tolerate it are
you going to arrest students
who might make fun of other students i
mean were
is that what you're going to do are you
going to start arresting people who mock
people what do you mean we will not
tolerate it as a representative of the
state so that's what's going on in new
york and now let's throw back
to that tucker clip with ron desantis
related to
bullying or and masks and covet and the
whole damn thing
well tucker none of the adults were
wearing masks and it seemed to me that
someone told those kids they had to do
it so i just wanted to make it very
clear they do not need to be doing it
obviously in florida it's a free state
you can do it but i think it's also
important to point out that there's no
reason to do it for for young and
healthy kids especially in the state of
florida we never had a mass mandate of
course but our guidance from our health
department is not to wear these cloth
masks and i think it needs to be said
because people have been lied to for two
years and so i was uh i didn't want it
to be thinking that like they were told
to do this by me because i certainly
wouldn't do that and you know they talk
about oh by letting someone have a
choice to take off their mask and
welcoming that choice that that's
somehow bullying tucker bullying is
locking kids out of school which they
did bullying is forcing kids to wear
masks for eight hours a day which they
did for two years and they're only
stopping now because the pollings change
bullying is kicking people out of work
because of vaccine mandates we fought
all of those policies in florida we
lifted people up and we liberated them
from local school boards and governments
that
that's my governor do you see what they
do they are the bullies they are the
hysterical authoritarians they're the
ones who have ruined so many people's
lives and broke these young people to
the point that even now
today you still see young healthy high
school kids wandering around in masks
because of the fear that these people
have put on so telling people hey you
don't have to wear the mask that's not
the bullying tactic they are the bullies
they do all the bad stuff and then they
call everyone else bad guys we have to
really understand what that is so that
we know how to behave better when it
happens and desantis really is becoming
a master of it this is a good transition
to now what's going on in new york city
so you may remember that new york city
got rid of the reign of terror of bill
de blasio the socialist maniac who
ruined new york city for about eight
years and they voted in this other
democrat mayor eric adams who just took
over in the last couple months who once
again my my good liberal friends who i
suppose are well intentioned but ever
get everything wrong they said no he
won't be a radical he'll be good
yeah well here he is keeping kids
toddlers toddlers in masks if you were
talking to a four-year-old and they're
trying to explain why they have to keep
their mask on but their their
six-year-old brother doesn't what what
is your your explanation to that
four-year-old i'm so happy you said that
because when i was in rockaway in the
saint pat state parade i did just that a
group of parents brought me and talked
to their children and explained
to them i told them you're going to be
taken off your mask like your big
brothers and sisters are doing now you
know when when you have big brothers and
sisters sometimes they do things first
to make sure it's safe for you and those
children they understand it because they
trust their parents and they trust their
leadership they're not tainted like
adults you know they still feel that we
have to make the right decisions for
them and i'm with the parents i want
those mask off i said it in january but
i have to do it right to make sure city
protect his children and don't close
down the city again
we really live in two different
countries perhaps it's more than two
different countries at this point but i
i don't live in the same country as that
man i don't want to live in the same
country as that man i want people like
him to have absolutely nothing to do
with me and that is why right now we are
building a giant moat around my house as
i said the other day we're putting we're
filling it with gators and i just put an
order in we we sent the the paperwork
over to israel i'm getting an iron dome
system around my house i want nothing to
do with these people now notice of
course let's just do the easy stuff up
top he didn't say one thing about
science right so there is 100
no science that has
come out anywhere that it says that
toddlers he's talking about two and
three-year-olds have to be uh masked
while they're older brothers who should
do stuff before them uh while they don't
have to be masked okay so there's no
sign so he quoted no science there
and then
the line that really gets you
these kids he's talking about these
toddlers they're not tainted like adults
think about what that means what he's
right they're not tainted like adults
kids come into this world and they're
they're born free and they're they're
naive the world is just the world is
what is put in front of them and then
they need adults to teach them how to
think they need adults to teach them
what freedom is and to be able to
critically think about what's going on a
toddler cannot do that so if you force a
toddler to wear a mask and then make
them one day when you're five years old
you'll be able to take off the mask
they're just gonna believe you so they
are breeding a generation of robots and
that's what they want they want a bunch
of dependent depressed robots i'm sorry
there's just no other way to look at
that i just don't know how you could
possibly
see it any other way and remember he was
supposed to be the good guy he's not as
crazy as lefty lunatic bill de blasio
that's what they said um and i'm sorry
if you if you now have a child that's
three years old and you are living in
new york city under the rule of that man
you're a child abuser in essence i don't
see a way around it you're a child
abuser you are letting the state abuse
your child put your children in mass we
know kids are getting mouth sores it's
causing delayed speech and depress all
of the stuff
you all know all this stuff and if
you're just letting them do it then uh
congratulations your kids are going to
put you in a really really cheap old age
home one day where you'll most likely be
abused by one of their friends but
there's more from uh new york city
because some parents have had it he said
that the good he made it seem like the
parents want this right this is what the
parents want because i love parents uh
not exactly the truth we've got some
info here from the new york post
roughly a hundred parents and children
gathered in front of new york's uh city
hall monday to protest continuing mass
mandates for the city's youngest kids
there is nothing i wouldn't do to keep
my daughter safe but it is my fervent
belief a belief supported by science
that continuing to mask two to
four-year-olds is unnecessary said dr
megan martin who has two children's
two children ages six and four masking
tauts hampers their development and must
be abandoned she argued the policy does
real harm to their education and social
growth she said and it was the oath i
took as a physician to first do no harm
that is bringing me here today the rally
goers said they plan to file a lawsuit
that will challenge the ongoing face
covering requirement for children for
and under if you want to know sort of
what level
what level of abject [ __ ] we're
dealing with do you remember what
happened a week ago today do you guys
remember what we were doing a week ago
today remember we ordered some pizza and
some tequila and we watched that elderly
man give that ridiculous speech where he
slurred all his words yeah i remember
that that was a week ago that was the
state of the union that was joe biden
he's 81 years old is that right how old
is joe biden something like that or he's
78 81 whatever he is but the guy's
obviously not doing so great with a
bunch of other geriatric old people most
of them who have trouble standing up out
of their chairs he's 79 years old thank
you
but he acts 81
they were all in a room
that was closed that was not outdoors
uh and they were hugging and kissing and
spitting all over each other nancy
pelosi was rubbing her evil claws
together remember that as she sat right
behind old joe um
the day before that joe was wearing a
mask that day he didn't wear a mask the
day after he was wearing a mascara it's
all theater it's all [ __ ] i just
don't know what you what they have
done how did they take the [ __ ] thing
out of your brain that makes you think
but they did it and congratulations to
them for being very good at what they do
even though they're very evil um but
which is more dangerous which is really
think about it please scientists if
you're a scientist if you're a media
matters guy who watches my show please
help me
please help me please show me the study
that shows me it's more dangerous for
three-year-olds to be unmasked than joe
biden and nancy pelosi please show it to
me but i get
that you can't do it i know you can't
but please do i'll gladly send me a
video we'll play it here i won't even
comment on it i mean that
back to florida where good things are
happening our surgeon general here is a
gentleman by the name of joseph joseph
ladapo and he has really become an
all-star in all this we've talked about
him a bit on the show uh if his politics
were a little bit different a young
black man that's a surgeon general of a
major state would be a huge star right
he'd be on newsweek he'd be on time he'd
be on cover in new york times every day
everyone would tell you how great he is
now unfortunately he happens to work for
a scary don't say gay conservative so
you don't hear much of this guy but he
is just knocking it out of the park
defending freedom and actually talking
about where the real science is uh here
he is talking about uh masks and the
nonsense around masking you know it's
hard to find
it's hard to find these in in florida
you got to look you got to look hard
but you know if you if you know where to
look you can find them so i brought i
brought this right
so unfortunately we have a country right
now where most people including i mean
this is across across the political
spectrum think that these things are
saving lives so to the doctors who tell
you that these things save lives
ask them
ask them
you know
what what did the what did the two
randomized clinical trials that we've
done during the pandemic what did they
show
ask them that when they tell you that
these things save lives
one found nothing
zero benefit
the other found
a small benefit like a tiny benefit
that's you know that's a little bit
methodologically shaky
and by the way none of them
none of them found a benefit in young
people not a single one found a benefit
in young people
that's the highest quality evidence
that's what it showed
lower evidence is what the cdc likes to
tell you know shaky studies shaky
methods finding 80 reductions in
infection give me a break you know i
mean come on you know nothing that we're
seeing in this in this country justifies
that kind of conclusion good doctors who
were brave enough to say what the
science show
got punished and that's happening and
it's still happening where people are
still holding up the illusion that these
things save lives
do you guys get that feeling that i keep
talking about when i play these clips
where someone tells the truth when you
hear desantis tell the truth or hear our
surgeon general tell the truth or the
rare moments that someone outside of
florida tells the truth like it actually
it feels lightening right like you feel
like a weight is lifted off your chest
because it's like we should
be hearing truth from the people that we
elect we should be hearing truth from
the people that are in charge of these
states we should be hearing truth from
our media and everywhere else it's not
that hard
it really isn't that hard it's what's
right and for some reason we're doing
the whole damn thing backwards but it
was so interesting what he said there he
quoted studies did you notice that
quoted actual studies
so again media matters or washington
post or whatever like fact check the guy
why don't you fact check the guy i think
we know why you know in fact check the
guy he talked about the methodology
right
um he's showing you that there is no
benefit to any of this and if there was
if there was then why would florida
which has been open for two years and
everywhere i go everywhere i go whether
i'm in miami or i was on the other coast
last week and i've been up north and
i've been to the middle of the state
everywhere i go everything is packed
very few people are wearing masks but
you can wear one if you want to and
nobody's bullying you for it
wouldn't the numbers be completely out
of control the morgues be overrun
florida has the second oldest population
in the united states etc etc it just
never ends but florida just has to keep
leading and that's exactly what it's
doing we've got some more info here from
the new york post florida will become
the first state in the nation to
formally recommend against covid19
vaccines for healthy children a local
official said monday florida surgeon
general joseph latipo who you just saw
there
announced the move which would defy
guidance issued by the federal centers
for disease control and prevention and
that all
that all children ages five to seven
should be
vaccinated
now it's funny because uh what florida
does everyone ends up doing
two years later so most likely this is
what's gonna happen everywhere else uh
we shall see but it's like this this is
what i mean about two countries this is
absolutely what i mean about two
countries it's like you can either live
in a place
where you have a new york city mayor
uh telling you that we're gonna mass
two-year-olds for no reason other than
he i think he wants to abuse children i
i cannot see it any other way no science
supports it two years after two two
weeks to flatten the curve so you can
either live in that city or you can live
his governor kathy seaword in a place
where uh she's now mostly worried that
the masked are gonna be bullied these
people are they're so backwards it's
extraordinary uh let's give dr lattipo a
little more credit today uh here he is
talking about the new guidance here in
florida and he is not happy with fauci
in the cdc
it's really been a tragedy that my
colleagues my physician colleagues have
decided that it's more important to
stick with whatever the cdc or dr fauci
is saying than relying on their clinical
wisdom experience and scientific
expertise which is what doctors usually
do so now doctors who practice medicine
in the way that they think is most
appropriate to there for their patients
when they're when they receive pushback
from hospitals we have an avenue for
them to to file a complaint with our
agency for healthcare administration
that they that the hospital is
interfering with their ability and their
clinical judgment in terms of what's
best for their patients
isn't it also the tone that he talks
with where it's like oh it actually just
kind of feels honest and it doesn't feel
like he's a [ __ ] artist or trying to
control you it's not just that he's
talking about the studies and that it's
couched in the idea of that we should
all make choices for ourselves and and
doctors should follow the science not
follow fauci it's also just like the
general feeling like he comes off as a
decent guy now go back later and watch
that video of kathy hoechel again with
the crazy eyebrows uh talking about
bullying when she is the biggest bully
in all of new york
i just want nothing to do with these
people in case that is not clear a
couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com
owen
says every day desantis pushes me
further and further to finding a job in
florida yeah look
i assume if you're a member of the
reuben report community you're going to
vote the right way but like there's room
in florida there's a booming economy
here which is not happening in the rest
of the country uh we want more good
people here i think i mentioned this the
other day but when i saw desantis speak
at an event a few days ago he mentioned
that when he came into office there were
300 000 more registered democrats than
republicans he's only been office for a
couple years and now there are about a
hundred thousand more registered
republicans than democrats so there's a
huge sea change here and it's not
because people hate science and it's not
because people hate gays or anything
else it's because people want to live
freely so so get a job here move your
family here bring your resources and
your love of life and let's keep making
this place better yeah awesome uh
gelerish says when i was in third grade
i still thought girls had cooties wait
girls don't have cooties i was not
we're gonna have to get a fact check on
that one yes these crazy people like
legitimately crazy people i mean you
just really have to think about it and
maybe i'm sort of on this because i just
as i said i went to my niece's
seven-year-old
birthday party at this place and we're
making the silly string and we're
painting and we're playing these squishy
balls and they like the uh the poppets
you know these things they like it's
interesting because kids right now they
seem to all love this tactile stuff that
you actually touch or pull or or mush
around in your hands and i think that's
partly because they're on ipads all day
long and they're at screens all day long
and zoom and all that so kids in reality
they want some reality um but the idea
that you would start talking to
seven-year-olds about gender identity or
sexuality it's it has nothing to do with
them and and yes if you were in the rare
rare rare let's say one percent case
where maybe
your seven-year-old child wanted to talk
to you about gender identity
or sexuality that should be done with
you as the parent not done at school by
some government employee it's just so
obvious and it's just another one of
those things where they have lied and
they're so over the top and they're
lying and they confuse so many
so many people it's just so twisted it's
so twisted man what are we gonna do
about it
abe says what do you suggest for those
of us in blue states that are still sane
but cannot afford to just pack up and
leave well first off
i've got the jar right here and i have
mentioned new york a couple times so i'm
gonna put some more cash in the jar this
is the leave cali fund and at the end of
the year i'm gonna give a whole bunch of
cash and i'll throw in a couple extra
thousand dollars myself to just move
somebody like i just want somebody to
get the hell out of california and come
here to florida you don't have to come
to florida realistically it's someone
that comes to florida maybe you can go
to texas or tennessee but i just want to
give someone here i'm putting in another
fiber okay because i just want good
people here but your question's a good
one because look not it's very difficult
to move people have all sorts of uh of
their own issues right like you might
have family uh elderly parents you might
have young cousins whatever it is like
you might have a business that you
started there although if you have a
business that you started in a place
like california it's probably not going
that well but we all have our own
considerations that's the point i mean
trust me when i decided to make the move
david actually was not as enthused as i
was at first i had to make sure that my
entire team wanted to come with me i was
a little worried about that once i said
it to everybody they were like yes let's
go tomorrow okay so it all kind of
worked out but it's just not easy to
move in general and it costs a lot of
money to move all your stuff and you
know there's all and you have to rebuild
a network of friends and rebuild a
business network and you have to find a
new dentist and a new hair stylist and
all of those things like it's not the
easiest thing but i would say at this
point
at this point the country is so broken
and so split and i don't know i just
don't know i don't say this with glee
but i just don't know what makes us the
united states of america anymore i don't
want anything to do with anything that
goes on in california and i don't want
any of those bad ideas infecting this
state and the states the good states are
going to have to continue to figure out
how do we
protect our freedoms
in the face of this never-ending federal
encroachment in the face of of big tech
lies and media lies and everything else
so if you're really really stuck there i
the best you can do
i think is build a really good community
of people around you whether that's
church or synagogue or
sports or whatever and and try not to
and try to get your kids out of school
if you're a parent i mean i would say
you know it's not like everyone wants to
be a homeschooler but now there's these
pods like there there are ways that you
can get some of the power back into your
hands but
the real thing is like figure out a way
to get out if you can i just don't see
how it turns around i just don't see it
um and by the way that's not that's not
really depressing it's not this is the
way it was all set up to be and it's
just becoming more and more stark and
enough people are going to move and then
and then of course the blue states will
declare war on the red states because
they're going to be jealous of the
freedom and the success and all that but
i think we got a couple years on that
one anywho uh guys don't forget to
pre-order don't burn this country at
daverubin.com
book i will be spending the next five
hours reading chapters four through six
i believe uh and the audiobook will be
out as well on april 12th in the year
2022
uh as always you can play along in the
live chat at reubenreport.locals.com and
part one of my interview with nikki
haley former u s ambassador to the un is
up on youtube and on rumble right now
the full thing is already up on locals
totally ad free
and as i said we we get into the russia
ukraine thing but i tried to do it at
sort of a high level thing not every
little nitty gritty we did some 101
stuff on the history of the area and
putin's ambitions but then really what
we talked about was policy like what are
sane policies what are ways that you can
have a foreign policy that makes sense
so that your interests are protected so
that you're not encroaching on other
people but you can also do some good
things in the world how do you blend
that with you know a more libertarian
approach of just stay out of people's
way and let let other countries do what
they want i think it's a really
interesting conversation and i'm fairly
certain you will dig it on that note i
have to stop talking for an hour because
i got a long afternoon of talking hope
you enjoyed the show have a great day we
will be back tomorrow